milking Charles winter nets is the
father of the modern Yale School of
Medicine dr. Wyn Ernest became Dean in
1920 and there was not really very much
in in structure in the Yale curriculum
at that time it was still a hangover
from the old curriculum where there were
a few professors but most of the
clinical training was done as
apprenticeships he was the first person
to take on the responsibility of
creating a real medical school here at
the University and actually in 1920 he
convinced the cooperation to do several
things one to say that the medical
school was going to be an integral part
of the University and to that it was
going to give support to the medical
school to build the best medical school
that a university should have I think
the curriculum reforms that he
instituted had several things one of
which was was reduced the number of
hours reduce the number of hours so as
to give the student more free time to
develop their own learning ability the
other curricular reform was to eliminate
the encumbrance of having to study for
examinations and and and a third reform
would be to give to the student the
opportunity to work with the faculty on
a on an in an intimate fashion so as to
develop their own ability to pursue
research or or the clinical ass
Milton winter nets created the Yale
system as a graduate system of medical
education he made the the Yale system of
medical education to be one not limited
to the four years five years of Noah of
medical school but to form the basis of
a lifetime of Medicine whether it be
academic or in practice it was a way of
saying to students you're here at the
Medical School you want to become a
physician you have to learn how to be a
physician I can't teach you
you